[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday
and then tearing [ __ ] up well just out
of the blue you start tearing [ __ ] up
huh
she's looking at me well i told i she
was doing that earlier today and because
she was destroying everything i started
singing at her anarchy in the bouquet
because i have a thing where i sing
pookie songs but i always like change
one of the words to her name yeah so and
i guess she likes it she doesn't run
away or yell at me so yeah but yeah okay
so we're gonna do uh gator this is the
uh sequel to white lightning we did the
white lighting i just got back from
biker bar
yeah so i only had a couple drinks so
he's all in he's all in the redneck
heads
right now yeah well you're always kind
of in a redneck head's face yeah
i had all kinds of cars and motorcycles
up there today it's sunday
yeah
yeah that's why i'm relate coming on
yeah maybe we should probably push the
matinee
just generally on sunday till five just
so we can have like longer because
sometimes we're out doing stuff on
weekends five or six yeah i mean you
know that would probably be fine i mean
we can still do it at three o'clock on
mondays and tuesdays but yeah or unless
you just want to move everything to 5
p.m across the board i don't know how
that makes me feel sensitive
because then everybody would remember
right you know what i mean and it would
be easier she's going to tear it up
again what are you tearing [ __ ] up for
dude
[Laughter]
okay so
i don't know if you guys watched white
lightning uh you know on our
recommendation uh on that last one but i
really we really i really enjoyed white
lighting jenny seemed to like it it's
got good um
uh comments
on the uh
the youtube uh
show so youtube has that for free with
commercials got this one up for free too
on youtube yeah somebody just said uh
the moviegator showed up on my youtube
feed free with ads yeah so you can
actually watch this
although the weird thing is that we
watched it on youtube and we didn't get
any ads no ads it just went freeze every
now and then it would freeze and i'm
like do you have like an ad blocker or
something that's like not and he says he
doesn't so because we watched it on our
big tv on the xbox yeah and it's a
direct um
sequel to white lightning and this was
directed by uh bert himself this was his
directorial debut
the uh the the gator
it's not a trilogy it's just two of them
uh the gator series was uh by
southerners force others and about
southerners
uh [ __ ] and all kinds of [ __ ]
all kinds of shits um
uh included in this one
um
jewish guys from new york show up uh
more black people all the shit's
resolved by pokemon yeah we're black
people also there's a cat lady who's
played by the same woman i can't
remember that actress's name but the
same woman that played the shop teacher
in greece yeah yeah what's that actually
this name i can't remember but she's in
it yeah and i'm a crazy cat lady this
one is actually the budget is bigger
than white lightning
um it seems to be bigger oh
it's kind of filmed a little bit better
in certain ways it's not quite as
[ __ ] raw
there's something about the first one
it's kind of like mad maxish
in this one
gator's a little more seems to be kind
of like a little more refined or a
little more civilized i mean it's
supposed to be three years later i think
or you know or okay here's one thing
though because i'm kind of concerned
about the time or confused about the
timeline yeah
in the original movie
uh white lining did they mention that
gator mccluskey had a daughter
no okay so in this one
that's what i'm saying he has a daughter
in this one and she's like yeah i was
gonna say like 11 or 12. yeah she's like
older yeah and so i'm assuming that even
though there were only three years
between the movies maybe it was supposed
to be a bigger time job
i'm not really entirely sure right and
it does look like the south had
developed quite a bit
maybe that maybe the uh
maybe the dates are wrong
because it looks like it looks like the
60s almost in in white lightning
but then uh in this one it looks more
like late 70s
it isn't though it's 76 76 77 this came
out 76 this came out okay
you know what's hilarious is that
burt reynolds like a lot of actors i
guess uh you know he'd been in a bunch
of movies at this point and he you know
of course they all like what i really
want to do is direct and what he wanted
to do is direct now this was the first
script that he was offered to direct
when he first read the script like to be
in it because they were like hey we're
making a sequel to white lightning
here's the script and he's like when i
first read it i'm like this is a
terrible script and then they said oh
but you can direct it and he's like oh
my god this is the best script ever
so
so the fact that he would like they let
him and he went on to do other
and actually he said that he actually
liked directing a lot better than acting
um
but he's like he got so busy with acting
because of the success of this movie and
others that he didn't really have a lot
of time but he did go he directed
sharky's machine which i didn't realize
um and stick
and uh a couple like
several other ones
so but this was his first one that he
did he did a pretty good job i'm not
it's hard because
white lightning
was like you said more like a southern
like an action movie there was like lots
of car chases and there was that and
this one it has like a boat chase at the
beginning uh which is very similar to
the stuff that you saw in white
lightning and it has a couple other car
chases in there this one i would call it
more of a crime thriller slash romance
yeah sort of it's kind of like some
social commentary yeah kinda because uh
all right well a lot of stuff happens in
like gator's next mission
uh he sees a lot of [ __ ] he doesn't
approve of you know something that's
what the southern mob is doing
a lot of people might not know but there
was a big southern mob
some of it directly at directly tied to
the italian mobs
from
new york
you see uh
when new york got a little too heavy
in the 60s and the 70s for some of those
gangsters
they would run to new orleans and they
kind of took over new orleans and some
of the other little cities there and
started new crime
syndicates um there was a movie called
um bullet to the head by uh um sylvester
stallone was kind of recent
and uh he plays a mob hitman in new
orleans
and which is kind of on that same
subject but there was a southern mafia
that kind of came out of all that and
and and this movie is kind of about that
um
a uh
guy from the uh
from the justice department in new york
uh comes down and
they're doing an investigation one of
the local mayors is
is running
an organized crime syndicate
and i don't remember exactly how it
happened they wanted gator to go in
there and investigate it do you remember
how that it was because and this one i
because i kind of feel like in the first
one that the feds like let him out of
prison to go because his family was in
moonshining and stuff
this one he had just got out of prison
again like for another moonshining
charge so he was out legitimately
they wanted him to infiltrate
uh the operation because the boss of it
bama mccall
was an old friend of his
so he would be able to get into the
guy's organization without him being
suspicious so it's similar to the first
story where you know he's using his
connections in the criminal underworld
right to
you know endear himself to these words
to get dirt on them is what he's trying
so there's a whole bunch of southern
slash new york
jokes on this new york guy you know what
i mean [ __ ] the
the mayor
like it meets him and and
and
is just [ __ ] funny you know i mean it
was just kind of showing
how everybody was stereotyped each other
back then
he meets the guy from the justice
department he goes oh yeah yeah i saw
fiddler on the roof three times so the
guy's like wow
but there's a lot of good humor in it
[ __ ] you couldn't get away with today
probably i don't know you probably could
yeah
the
and then the [ __ ] gator finally he he
gets a job in there and this time i was
right see the dude from [ __ ] smoking
the bed at the guy that jerry reed was
jerry reed is in this and he plays he
wasn't in the first one but in the
person i thought that was him but well
now jerry reads in this one he does a
[ __ ] great job i can't believe that
dude he's playing a villain playing a
villain which he doesn't usually and him
and burt reynolds did i mean yeah most
famously they did smoky in the bandit i
think they did another movie together
called
wwe and the dixie dance kings i want to
say and i think that jerry reid played a
good guy because he's so affable yeah um
you know intimidating but in this one he
plays like a really yeah bad dude i mean
even though he still has that that's
funny funny like charming southern kind
of thing but he's like a total sleeve
yeah he's pimping out 13 15 year old
girls and [ __ ] doesn't and then he's
giving him drugs and like stuff
and so and then he's got he's got
[ __ ] um he's got gator going out
shaking down uh poor black businesses
for [ __ ] protection money and [ __ ]
like that and gator's like [ __ ] he's
having a hard time dealing with it he
doesn't want to do it
um but it's part of his mission you know
what i mean he's got to infiltrate this
yeah so he's really conflicted about it
because he's like this is i'm assuming i
don't think they go too much into it but
yeah bama was like an old friend of his
and i guess they haven't seen each other
in a long time so you know he goes up
there and then i think that when he sees
the extent to which
you know because burt reynolds character
gator is kind of like i don't mind a
little criminality you know what i mean
obviously because he's doing moonshine
and all that but
the extent that
bama's uh racket has gone to where like
you said they're essentially pimping out
they're drugging and pimping out like
teenage girls yeah um you know among
other things and like you said yeah from
good families right and like and just
implied that yeah girls from and shaking
down like these you know like in the
poor black areas like the business
owners shaking them down for money and
[ __ ] like that
um
and you know and he's having a hard time
like going along with it even like
pretending to go along with it you know
and then they had they had to shake down
the uh the black gangsters too
uh remember that and they got into
they got into a chase slash gun fight
but at the end they
nobody killed each other it was like
part of the game they're like okay i'll
give you the money you know because they
were
uh it didn't really explain it why it's
just it was something that had been
going on between
him and that gang for a long time this
big cat and mouse game but in the end
they just decided to pay they were some
kind of
i don't think they could kill each other
there was some kind of a
symbiotic relationship that they somehow
needed each other to run these criminal
empires that they were doing probably
supplying each other with stuff they
couldn't survive without each other or
something
uh did you remember that scene yeah when
they got him but i had to go back and
see it again i forgot the details of why
they weren't killing each other
um maybe it was just well maybe it was
just like it was like mutually assured
destruction type situation where it's
just kind of like well we can't do that
because then it'll like just mark off
this big huge [ __ ] yeah you know and
nobody wants to to do that yeah that was
a pretty that was a pretty fun scene
grantham says bama mccall classic you
know what's funny i was watching like a
little mini documentary about this movie
and uh because i was wondering about
that too i just assumed he was called
bama because he was from alabama but
they said no actually when burt reynolds
and jerry reed were talking about the
character uh burt reynolds apparently
says to jerry reid who was like the
meanest kid in your high school or in
your school and he said it was this kid
named bama mccall so it was he was named
after a real person
or like the most badass kid in your
school or whatever so they named it
after a real person that's that's how
the story goes um i like this one though
um
it was kind of in a way
and kind of in a way of a better
portrayal of the south just it wasn't
all shot in the junkiest of places it
showed that no they were real nice
places too real up upscale plate
locations in the south real nice hotels
real shitty hotels
you had real [ __ ] shitty [ __ ]
black neighborhoods and then really cool
[ __ ] black clubs that were like
high-end after that one thing happened
there's a good scene where they go in
there to shake them down that's where
they ran into the black gangsters
and [ __ ] they had some [ __ ] black
hot black stripper chick up there
dancing and [ __ ] the gangster ass
[ __ ] so so would you would you do it
and he was like oh you know new york
made it everybody said new york like new
york second or some [ __ ] like that well
no new york manager
i don't know well yeah that's a that's a
pretty common uh yeah i don't know
that's a pretty cool never even heard of
it yeah that's that's a very common
aphorism okay so uh anyway and then they
had then they they went to that
uh
chase it was just kind of good because
it showed more of the south that it was
kind of a wider spectrum of it
um
the
uh
a lot of it looked like south florida or
assuming uh northern florida panhandle
and central florida well i think it was
supposed to be georgia but the thing
about it was that i'm not entirely sure
where they shot it
but
well it might have been very very south
georgia because they talked about um
you know in in the theme song which uh
the ballad of gator mccloskey which
jerry reed also sings and i was just
like man i want like some country singer
to like sing some ballad about my life
that'd be pretty rad it'd be boring but
it'd be it'd be funny but
uh he's talking about the he was
supposed to live like with his dad and
his daughter in the okefenokee swamp now
the okefenokee swamp if you don't know
is right on the border of florida and
georgia okay
so but some of the later scenes
uh
are coastal
and it looks like it looked like north
florida or perhaps very south georgia so
i think this is somewhere around the
florida georgia border is where this is
it makes sense because um burt reynolds
is from georgia yes his family's from
georgia even though he was born in
michigan his family was stationed there
when his dad was in the army and he was
i think he was only there when he was a
baby and then he moved back to georgia
so he's directing so he's probably gonna
put it where he's from or in that area
where he's from that's where he's gonna
film it that's probably you're probably
right it's probably right up there on
the border of
georgia and florida
makes sense i was thinking too that uh
jerry reid's character bama mccall
also has
two henchmen
one of which is named bones who is this
big giant
like seven foot five dude
who some of that is it's weird because
they call this a comedy it has i don't
know if i'd call it a comedy it has
funny [ __ ] in it
but it's not like a laugh a minute and
honestly some of the [ __ ] in it is like
kind of disturbing like especially the
one scene where
bama has just like apparently had sex
with a drugged up 15 year old and then
kind of leaves her to like burt reynolds
like oh hey enjoy yourself bye you know
what i mean and you know burt reynolds
who has a daughter like a not much
different age than that is just kind of
like this is [ __ ] up and it's just
like you know i mean the dude yeah well
obviously yeah because he's a good guy
if he did do it he wouldn't be the good
guy anymore but um but so there's that
so it's tonally it's kind of
strange because like i said i don't
think i would call it a comedy but
bones this big huge henchman
is so tall the joke goes that when he's
driving the car his head like his head
and shoulders like stick out of the
top of the sunroof yeah so there's that
and also he has this other henchman
called smiley yeah who is like
he's like a predatory yeah homosexual
type character like and all he does is
smile and he has like these big [ __ ]
teeth like this yeah there's some pretty
good scenes where he gets up on [ __ ]
and gets up on gate he goes so you were
in prison he said yeah you said like i
heard there's a lot of homosexuals in
prison he's like yeah yeah yeah he just
gets creepier and creepier and creepier
trying to make a move on and get him to
crack and he's he's trying to [ __ ]
pretend like he's not affected
it's a good one
started [ __ ]
skeeving out on him
yeah and then uh but it's a good flick
it's got a lot of uh
they go to a lot of locations it's got a
lot of uh interesting characters
a lot of cool interaction uh some people
in there giving quotes you know yeah i
heard you hired some new bowsers bounce
when i'm off the wall another bounce
another one through a glass window yeah
there's good quotes in it i did like i
did like very hard
[Laughter]
and then
gator meets this uh news reporter
yeah i was just gonna say this was
actually i don't know if this was lauren
hutton's first movie but it was her
first major
role for sure because she'd been a model
prior to this yes they start falling in
love with each other they're totally
different he's he's
of course you know real redneck you know
and she's she's from the south but she's
she's she's middle class you see that's
another thing i liked about the movie
they showed the the the south's class
system
uh people that lived
in towns in a suburban setting were
pretty much like anyone else anywhere
else in the united states they were they
were southerners but
their thinking was very middle class and
very conventional the country people
were wild
and
there was a lot of [ __ ] that was going
on and that that showed
and then
the aristocracy sometimes tended to be
[ __ ] corrupt in which it showed that
also um and the government was very
corrupt local governments tended to be
it depended on where you were
um
but uh i just like the fact that they
they showed that there's not one kind of
person in the south there's a bunch of
them
well the thing that i really liked about
this one is that
you i mean burt reynolds character in it
you know he's kind of like a redneck and
stuff in white lightning but he was
still like a likeable you know he wasn't
stupid or not like any of the other like
stereotypes more of an ex-con flavor to
him right in white lightning this one he
seemed like a lot more like he'd uh
grown a lot more like chilled out
matured a lot more
and i liked the relationship that they
established between him and lauren
hutton because
she was very i mean this came out in
1976 so she was very much career woman
you know she was trying to get ahead in
her profession and she was very feminist
and he was like okay with that and like
there wasn't even really a lot of like
back and forth about it they were just
kind of like
immediately sort of like saw each other
as equals even though they were
different i also kind of like to at the
end can i spoil the end like the end of
the love story yeah and at the end she
gets like this big um
promotion or she gets uh she needs a job
she gets like a job at cbs like to go
national and she wants to she wants to
like move to the big city because she
says early on she's like look i don't
want to live in a [ __ ] backwater
swamp okay and you can't really like
blame her she's like i said a career
woman
and uh you know they do love each other
like they fall in love but um you know
she's like
at the end they kind of like say well we
can't really be together because he
wants to stay in the swamp and she
doesn't want to yeah and he's just kind
of like
you know and he just like lets her go
and he's like cool about it and they're
you know they're sad but
yeah
which i tried to straighten it out in
the beginning of the movie they show him
and his daughter and his dad
and they're living
in in in a sw on a swamp yes in a swamp
in the ocean
and it's it's never really clear if that
was the fishing camp or if they were
actually living in there i think it was
the fishing camp
a lot of southerners in the in the
country have multiple kind of little
houses one of them is the main house
that they live in they go to work from
that one that's when they live in but
then they have like a cabin or a hunting
cabin or a hunting lodge or a fishing
lodge
on a body of water somewhere in the
boats down there because
land isn't that expensive and a lot of
times two or three guys will go to get
go together on a single little fishing
cabin and get it together
and you know they wrote rotate through
it you know they're not all using at the
same time it's you know
chances of them all being there at once
pretty slim it doesn't matter they're
all going fishing anyway
so i
they they showed some pretty cool swamp
boat fights that's why you want to put
it they're running through people's damn
swamp houses and [ __ ] and the daughter's
there find out that the daughter
she doesn't want to go to school i don't
think she's ever been to school huh
and he says no you're going to school
yeah i'm not going she's like [ __ ] that
she doesn't say that but yeah but
basically she's like nah
well and the thing about it and i think
i forgot to mention this is that that's
kind of how they uh you know convince
gator to go along with this mission that
they're doing is they basically say you
go along with it or we're going to
arrest your dad that's right and put
your daughter in foster care right yeah
you know so yeah because
that's right because like at first he
was just like no i don't want to do it
yeah and they don't like i said they
only got him into it because he had been
acquainted with bama mccall like a long
time ago and said they thought oh okay
we go see him like he's your old friend
and you can like infiltrate his
organization and see what the [ __ ] is
going on because again they were trying
to get dirt on somebody which is where
the cat lady comes into it the cat lady
or shop teacher from greece
she uh worked at the courthouse stop it
so she worked at the courthouse so she
had um access to like a lot of records
that
you know were incriminating
and she still had keys
so she so
this last there was this one like kind
of long sequence
where they go on this kind of like
hijink-filled adventure
of them trying to like break into the
courthouse after hours to like get these
papers
and she insists on bringing her two cats
with her because they're her babies
so the two cats have to come with them
on the uh on the mission
and sadly
the cats um
cats die and she died today i think they
the cats don't make it
they don't show i mean they don't die
they don't die on the mission but
afterward like they go to this other
beach house because they they get made
and then they're like oh [ __ ] we got to
go hide somewhere so they go to this
beach house that belongs to like lauren
hutton's uncle or some [ __ ] so they're
out there but then like the gangsters
find them
and burn the house down
um
yeah and she runs back in to get the
cats which you know i can't blame her i
would do that too but um but yeah she
gets killed so presumably the cats get
killed too unless they jumped out a
[ __ ] window or something so i just
have to tell everybody because maybe
people get upset with that too like
everyone's like when something bad
happens to an animal in the movie i just
have to like warn people you don't see
it or anything but the implication is
that the cats don't make it and the cat
lady doesn't make it either but yeah so
that's what i mean i i liked this
i'm not sure which one i liked better
because this one
i like there was a lot more [ __ ] in this
one that i liked but it was a little
uneven like the toe it was totally a
little bit uneven it was less like an
action like a southern action movie and
more like
a crime thriller
love story with
some funny stuff in it you know what i
mean
that said though i don't know i i liked
the story in this one better i think
because i kind of liked i liked all the
gangster [ __ ] and i really liked seeing
jerry reed
playing a complete scumbag because i
think that was the first time i'd ever
they're both good but they're both
different it's kind of like comparing
mad max and and road warrior road
warriors better but mad max is [ __ ]
good too yeah it's the same thing this
movie i think is a little more it's a
little better than white lightning
but white lightning's nothing to to
laugh at either that's something you'd
want to see you want to see them both
they're just different they're they're
offering different things with the same
characters it's the same spirit in the
movie yeah you know
this one is more ambitious i think you
know every budget in the sense of it
having like a larger like more
convoluted story i guess the only only
thing i can knock it on is that um
the
after the after the scene
with the underage prostitution it was
pretty dark right there yeah i had to
lighten it up real quick that's what
they did they decided to lighten it up
real quick with these romance scenes
and it didn't quite flow that's what i
meant like for it being like a little
bit tonally uneven tone what kind of
went uneven there should have been some
more stuff that happened in between
those scenes yeah because on being like
you know teenage press drugged
prostitution that's going a little dark
and then the next one to have kind of
like a goofy hey look at my movie it was
i don't think that was the next
movie resolved that he never got they
never did did they and i think i when we
were watching that i think he'd go back
and saved her yeah i was thinking that
at the end i was like holy [ __ ] i don't
think they ever like addressed
uh i mean i because that's the thing
like you assume yes you know bama mccall
was defeated in the end or presumably
arrested or whatever the hell um but but
what happened to her but what happened
to her like did his next in command just
did he just take over and like nothing
changed or whatever can we also talk
about
that one scene toward the end
where that car
goes off that sort of like ramp thing
like onto the beach yeah and
yeah it just got stuck that's good stuff
um that was i believe that was hal
needham who was the same guy that he's
the stunt coordinator he was the stunt
coordinator on uh smoking the bandit as
well and i think that was him because i
think he was doubling burt reynolds in
that and he almost got killed yeah and
if you watch that stunt
uh
yeah because i was like watching that
going holy [ __ ] [ __ ] is that guy okay
it's right out of mad max actually some
beverly some of the mad max stuff this
car ramps through the air and there's a
dude on the side of the car holding
holding on to it
but
he's he he jumps out of the damn
driver's side and he's holding on to the
[ __ ] driver's side with the door and
go and and then and the car hits the
ground with him hanging on the side of
the car and then he's just like falling
a long way and i mean damn sad the car
easily could have fallen on him i mean
it was like inch it looked like it was
like inches yeah and i was like like i
said i was watching something earlier
like kind of about the making of this
and burt reynolds i think did say
something about yeah it was like inch
that car was [ __ ] inches from hitting
him and then like they went up to him
after going like holy [ __ ] are you all
right and he's like did you get it was
it good you know what i mean it's like
that because i was even impressed by
that [ __ ] stunt i was like that
looked like it really could have gone
wrong not a good mafia
mafia uh what a mafia but you know
southern [ __ ]
southern mafia shotgun [ __ ]
assassinations and blasts on people um
some pretty good
action there a couple of gun fights it
was a satisfying movie it was pretty
good pretty good adriana says was burt
reynolds like a southern american bond
type back in the day yeah i guess so
um not more kind of like down to earth
i guess james bond if he was southern
would be a dude coming out of jail down
to earth probably he would be a redneck
he's just kind of like he's almost kind
of like a laid-back anything else
wouldn't would not would stand out in
the south yeah because he's like
laid-back and kind of funny and yeah
kind of and real charming yeah you know
what i mean so yeah it's similar
kind of uncivilized to a certain extent
yeah kind of but not that bad i mean
it's not you know in one seat of the
movie he tells uh the news reporter girl
you know they're laying together and he
goes yeah i guess i don't have any style
he says i should have been born 100
years ago back when not having a style
was a style
and you guys know you got style you got
all kinds of stuff and he was well you
know because he was saying that she had
style yeah but because she was like a
big city girl right yeah you got style
you got all kind of style and he was
like oh okay you don't get he's got a
mustache in this one he didn't have a
mustache in white lighting that's true
i'm just not used to seeing him without
a mustache his mustache is like its own
separate entity yeah it probably tells
him things but um
[Laughter]
but this movement is good enough to see
why smoking the bed had them both in it
because they [ __ ] did some good
acting in this
although i have to say some of the
scenes are like are just kind of like
the two of them like cracking up at each
other and i kind of wonder if they just
kind of were like doing that and they
just left it there's a lot of long
scenes where with of them [ __ ] with
each other it's kind of like something
quentin tarantino probably ripped off
like they yeah one time one time he
wants to leave the mob so they they
secretly slip him with mickey and his
drink and he starts
that's the thing i was thinking of
getting drugged they keep [ __ ] with
him and making fun of him while he's
going out and says you're gonna be all
right you're just gonna go to sleep and
i'm gonna put you in the back of the car
when you wake up you're gonna be in your
car outside of town and you know this is
but i can't hit you know and and all
kinds of i'm you know and then he's like
i'm gonna
it's just you just gotta see the scene
it's pretty good
you don't know whether or not they're
gonna kill him or if they're really
gonna let him go but they do let him go
well for a time until he comes he's like
[ __ ] this and he comes back right tries
to [ __ ] with them again
okay i guess we have to kill him now
yeah but um no you didn't let him go
though well at first they did yeah but
um
you know after after the end it was just
kind of like yeah because i think they
found out after that he was
working for
but it's uh they're both free i
recommend the series it's good it's a
good series uh if you're if you're if
you're
not american and you [ __ ] want to see
some the old south there's the south
that well it's not really the old south
it was like
the old south was back in the 1800s but
you know this was kind of the south that
i grew up in as a kid visiting my dad
during the summers you know this is the
south that my dad came from and that's
what i and [ __ ] it's accurate that's
way mostly well yeah and i remember a
lot of this stuff too from when i was a
kid yeah um that's kind of like the way
[ __ ] was and the attitude was younger
and the people the way they looked the
way they talked that's that's pretty
much it
they even had some hippies in it they
had those
yeah yeah they just were rare
they talked about
actually that was in the first movie
that was the first one i was gonna yeah
because i was sitting there trying to
remember what they're doing
yeah i kind of feel like the first one
had hippies the first one had hippies in
it but they but this one didn't happen
nobody's this was kind of more the
hippie thing had gone by kind of going
away yeah this was like late this was 76
yeah so i think this is more of the more
uh
uh some of it happens in in kind of
middle class towns and then um
uh gangsters
gangsters and nightclubs
yeah because i kind of i kind of feel
like the first one was almost all like
in the swamp or in like really really
lower income
neighborhoods you know among like liquid
moonshiners and stuff whereas this one
is kind of like across the board across
the board a little more a little more
exciting i think [ __ ] visually you
see more
yeah
and most of the things that you're
seeing in this are gone they're they're
torn down nothing looks like well yeah
this was a long time i got home but the
old corner stores the old little package
stores and the old little strip malls
they're all torn down they're all gone
even the roads don't look like that
anymore they all have [ __ ] gutters
and sidewalks and shits just in most you
have to go out of town they don't have
them but
in towns they do uh just
it's it looks
nowadays a lot of the south just looks
very much at least here in florida looks
very much like
like a disney theme park
manicured stuff well and i kind of feel
like suburban
suburban areas kind of look similar
everywhere in the country yeah um you
know because i've seen
you know [ __ ] from like suburbs all over
the us and they look very very similar i
mean other than like different kind of
trees and [ __ ] like get into the world
that they're talking about in the gator
series
you got to go out that way
about another 5-10 miles you'll start to
see that kind of stuff and then further
you go it's weird because the farms
sometimes will get bigger and richer and
have rich people out there
but they're country people that they got
cattle and all kinds of stuff you know
there's [ __ ] cows there's 200 headed
cows just a couple hundred meters away
from here
yeah we can walk to it yeah
you have rednecks and [ __ ] and you just
see some weird [ __ ] like you know you'll
see a [ __ ]
nice house brand new it's up on stilts
off the ground [ __ ] have about seven
or eight cars parked underneath there
and a whole bunch of harley davidsons
and it's just like expensive [ __ ] you're
like what does that do to do for a lives
i don't know and then you go a little
bit further and you'll be like yeah
you'll be like two or three trailers
hidden behind a bunch of bushes and you
can't really see there's a brand new
[ __ ]
brand new [ __ ] corvette parked there
and [ __ ]
nice [ __ ] you know it's not all just
these jalopies
they like [ __ ] like corvettes and the
new camaro
and sometimes not the entry models we're
talking about the high performance
editions of the camaros
uh you know they'll
they don't they don't mind [ __ ]
financing a [ __ ] badass muscle car
not not in the redneck south
and going to see where her parents live
and [ __ ] you going into there it's damn
american flags trump flags and [ __ ]
confederate [ __ ] battle flags all
down there remember that just [ __ ]
they they'll fly all those [ __ ] flags
and uh
i stopped at the liquor store and went
in there and [ __ ] i forgot how big
those [ __ ] are they're like
that whole there must been 20 people
waiting in line to pay for gas [ __ ]
most of them over six feet tall i felt
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the dudes are [ __ ] big
harley's everywhere
it's just uh it's it's a lot bigger
scale it's upscale now in gator's time
it's very low income
but it's funny because they're kind of
low income a lot of them but they just
have really nice [ __ ]
they just got good credit i guess
john smith says watching those stunts
from back in the day you knew lives were
on the line especially in the silent era
yeah yeah because they didn't have like
all the safeguards and [ __ ] that they
have nowadays uh you know they're like
hey stand over there and we'll shoot at
you we'll try not to hit you just you
know don't worry about it uh fourth
drawdown says hal needham also directed
hooper i remember that movie in which
burt reynolds actually plays a stuntman
yeah honestly this was one of the
like
this is one of the most harrowing like
stunts that i've seen like that dude
just coming off the car like that
because it looked like i mean it really
looked like something could have gone
horribly horribly wrong yeah slasher
fred says i wonder if burt reynolds had
ever been mistaken for dennis weaver
from duel yeah because they did look the
same i feel like the burt reynolds look
that was a that was a look in the
seventh right that was a whole you had
that roll bushy mustache she had kind of
a dark hair the cowboy hat yeah type
jeans or tight pads and then [ __ ]
look like you maybe like a work belt
around it's just something like that you
look like you were
there to
fix somebody's telephone or something
[ __ ] put up telephone lines which i
feel like yeah i mean reynolds is kind
of like the platonic ideal of that yeah
yeah he's just like the best looking
dude that looks like yeah that he came
over to like fix your telephone line
yeah
wichita lineman or whatever yeah
right
now we saw a movie uh last night it was
great it's also free on youtube gonna
plug it now so you guys can watch it
while it's still free and we're gonna
we're gonna talk about it tomorrow on
the matinee tomorrow it's called the
machinist no the mechanic mechanic okay
i got him confused the mechanic with um
uh charles brown charles bronson and the
[ __ ] dude from air wolf what was his
name
jan michael vincent wasn't that jammed
for damn yeah yeah michael visited it
was he on miami base
i don't know i don't think so i don't
think he's a miami vice i think he was
an air wolf wouldn't he or he was one of
those no wasn't he
wasn't he in eighty
yeah no i can't remember
i knew he was in something from the 70s
but i can't remember what it was anyway
uh the mechanic was about um the dude
who uh
played by bronson who's he's a uh
professional hitman an assassin he's
real good he's kind of he's weird he's
kind of like a serial killer got a weird
bad upbringing and
kind of um
kind of autistic a little bit around
people and uh jenny didn't catch it i
caught a [ __ ] huge gay undertone well
i'm not saying i didn't catch it i just
don't know if it was necessarily like
that pretty relevant to the plot it
might have been way they were shooting
stuff with dudes crotches and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] when the eye contact the
lingering eye contact
i think they were trying to say that
they were that they were in love with
each other
that's how i picked that up that sex was
happening man that dude walked in
[ __ ] jam michael vincent walked in
and [ __ ] they just zooms out on his
face and it zooms in then the eye
contact between him and then he plays it
off like
yeah
yeah they were trying to say that i
think they were trying to say that uh
there was some homosexuality going on i
mean there could have been but like i
said it doesn't i mean it doesn't like
factor into the plot and i know so
i think it did though because remember
how it ended
it was supposed to be like a real tight
relationship but then they broke up i
guess you could say
and then um
i guess you could call it i think that
yeah i think that element was supposed
to be in there and it wouldn't surprise
me if it was edited out
that's i don't know well like i said
we're not doing that movie till tomorrow
we're gonna do it tomorrow so save it
and then i'll do some research and see
what's going on hype plugged that much i
know but don't like that [ __ ] is bad
don't blow your whole load on it it's a
good movie that's a very good movie i
thought it was weird it's a weird 70s
it's michael winner i'd seen some other
michael winter movies i thought i saw
that one too but i couldn't uh i
couldn't remember yeah um let me see
there's another one on there it's called
mr majestic we're gonna see that one too
that one's good i remember that one
weirdly yeah well like i said this is
what happens when you have an ex-husband
that was super into like american action
movies because he was british uh so i
saw pretty much i saw every chuck norris
movie um in every charles bronson movie
because he really liked those two so i
saw like a [ __ ] ton of charles bronson
movies mr majestic 10 to midnight all
that kind of stuff 10 to midnight is
really good too you would probably like
that as well uh i think that's on amazon
prime for free now i'm thinking about it
slasher fred says smokey and the bandit
kind of brings back the days of cb radio
yeah it's like the weird thing is like
we watched that not too long ago and i
thought we did a matinee on it but i
guess we didn't maybe we should do that
at some point what's that uh smoking in
the bandit oh we yeah we need i thought
we too i think we talked about it on one
of our side tracks we saw it recently
yeah but we didn't yeah we didn't do a
matinee on it i think it was up for free
wasn't it no no we had to pay for no we
paid for it i think it was three nights
i also wanted to get uh do cannonball
run
yeah i haven't seen it in a long time
you know and there's sequels to smokey
in the band there's two sequels yeah and
i remember the second one i don't
remember if i ever saw the third one i'm
sure i did but i don't remember anything
about it um yes we were talking about
how burt reynolds was like the look of
the 70s and oracle said kind of like how
tom selleck was a look in the 80s yeah
you had like that type
you know whatever it was tell me to set
up a beat cb stages cb's out dude
everything now the closest thing to cb
would be gmrs i have gm rs and i have
ham capabilities
uh right now you want gmrs although you
want both but gmrs is really good
because you're only dealing with 22
channels and only a couple of repeaters
and it's it channels everybody right
into those 22 channels you don't have
millions of channels you only got 22.
so you when you have the thing on scan
you're more likely to hear radio traffic
it's real good for
in case cell phones or [ __ ] emps or
whatever you know what i mean you don't
have a computer system and
you can use
a ham repeaters and gmrs repeaters
because even on my little twenty dollar
cheapos my ham radios i'm hooked i got
programmed to talk to hit repeaters i
can hear people up in like uh maine and
kansas talking the thing is they're not
talking they're not talking about much
they they sign in all the same time
around 10 o'clock in the morning and
they all [ __ ] check in
and they just uh give the report of what
the weather's like where they are so
talk about weather and that's it so that
gets boring real quick
just talking about the weather
you know
it's just this i don't know the brits
have a whole culture he's going to talk
about the weather over there
so there's not really they're not really
then there's a bunch of government stuff
that's constantly playing but it's
mostly about weather
weather
i mean weather is to be fair like a big
part of people's day-to-day lives so
and in an emergency those weather
channels start giving you all kinds of
emergency information
hugo says i don't understand why people
get upset when animals die in movies but
they're okay with humans dying um i am
one of those people
i think it's because
in life as in movies most humans are not
all that likeable
uh so i don't really care if they get
killed
whereas kitties and doggies are
and bunnies are
little just innocent creatures they
don't know what's going on
leave them alone yeah and i think too
there's like kind of a thing too
particularly lately in horror movies and
i think i talk about it every time i do
a movie where something like this
happens i think they're like we're gonna
show you how [ __ ] up this movie is by
killing off like a cat or a dog i'm like
please don't
but i guess they do it like to
to piss off people like yeah i suppose
like kill all the people you want in the
movies i don't care but like leave the
damn cats alone yeah
let me respond in there yeah cb's dead
because cb's a little small part inside
the radio band it's not popular anymore
if you want to get back into it you can
get little gm gmrs radios general mobile
general mobile radio service and you
just pay for a license you don't really
need um any you know courses or anything
ham is a simple course but you can pay
for that too
but here's the thing
in an emergency situation anybody can
use those without a license and no one's
ever been arrested or fined for
not having a license just
it's kind of dumb you know it's not
we're not we don't live in the age of
radio anymore there's no problem with
abundance of radio traffic the most of
the radio spectrum is [ __ ] empty so i
don't really understand why you need any
permission to use it you need permission
to use your own free radio
bands it doesn't make any sense
yeah john smith says i was really into
listening to pirate radio back in the
day pump up the volume made it look a
lot cooler than it was yeah yeah i mean
that was an awesome movie right but
yeah i do kind of feel like i don't
really think they would even back then i
don't really think they would care all
that much at like some well their kid
doing a pirate radiation well there's
only like uh when it comes to the fcc
finding people there's only three or
four um
three or four instances of it and it's
usually somebody jamming somebody else's
yeah it would have to be like a way
bigger deal way
than just
in the movie i mean basically he was
just like talking about the corruption
at his high school right and playing
alternative music that had bad words in
it there was a i don't think anyone
would care there was one guy who was
running a pirate music radio station i
think was somewhere in la they came
they gave him a bunch of warnings over a
period of about 10 years eventually he
wasn't broadcasting on very much power
either so he wasn't really broadcasting
very far they came and took all his
radio [ __ ]
they didn't even find him they just took
all this [ __ ] two months later he bought
new [ __ ] and started it again and they
didn't do anything to him they just got
sick of him yeah they're just like
whatever yeah so
you just want to respect it you know you
don't [ __ ] jam up
you know whatever channel or frequency
you're on just uh but uh
you should understand it and [ __ ]
know about call signs or radio etiquette
if you're doing ham gmrs they don't
they're not [ __ ] worried about it
there's another one's frs which is uh
just like that's kind of like cb now
where you don't need anything you can
just talk on it
granters knows what it is i think it was
frs or or m-u-r-s i think that's also
that's just a little handheld 20 sets
you could get you can give to a kid you
know those are out there
but
there's no real
there's nothing there's nothing really
important happening on those
in that in those bandwidths
you know
yeah gram thirst has uh he's a ham user
calls on uh k-e-a-n-o-n most ham users
are old dudes who ramble on about
nothing in particular yeah uh and then
john smith brings up the website does
the dog die dot com
i don't know if they have a cat
equivalent or if they've already started
if they've started adding cats to that
but yeah pretty much any movie that you
can think of every time a movie comes
out you can go to the website does the
dogdy.com and it will tell you if the
dog dies and at what point the dog dies
in case you don't want to watch it so
yeah so it's they're doing it it's a
valuable service yeah
fr is family radio says grandpa says fc
can actually show up and demand to see
your radio come yeah that's true but
most of the guys are out there they have
those little [ __ ] uv5r balfang radios
they transmit five four and a half watts
you don't you can't really talk very far
on anyway you know unless you can bang
something off a repeater and a lot of
those guys aren't doing it they're just
talking to [ __ ] jed on the other side
of the [ __ ]
the other side of the thing you know
trying to
coordinate the [ __ ] sprinklers that
is that
sector three which sprinkler sprinklers
that you know they're just they're not
really talking on it they're just
working on it
using it as a tool and then that's it
nobody even hears it because you're you
can put them on low and transmitted a
half a watt and that won't go anywhere
you know
half a mile max if there isn't any
obstructions what's the chances of the
fcc intercepting you
within a half mile radius and [ __ ]
going how dare you [ __ ] with that that
thing while you're
trying to work out the sprinkler system
you know
adriana says did crocodile dundee try to
imitate gator for the australian market
uh well i don't know if it's so much an
imitation but australia and the united
states have very similar
cultural you know kind of uh context i
guess sometimes yeah so sometimes so
cowboy based yeah so i think there is
kind of like this whole like uh you know
sort of outback you know kind of thing
just paralleling our old west type thing
so i think they have same the same kind
of cultural archetypes that's a fish out
of water stories they've been making
those forever going yeah that's really
hillybillies that's true which is a
great tele tv series you can see it for
free on youtube without commercials each
one was only 15 minutes long without
commercials
but they're just funny little quick do
you know that our and pretty much our
most of our entire childhood uh you know
my brother would eat cereal out of this
massive bowl and we called it the jethro
jethro bowl
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that was part of the stereotypes of
[ __ ] country people being good
looking was like and jethro bodine shows
up and [ __ ] uh the damn
[ __ ] banker woman is just [ __ ]
head over heels for this [ __ ] big old
[ __ ] hillbilly it's like ooh look at
this big lunk head i mean yeah
yeah
[ __ ] jumping in the damn it's going
to see mint pounds
what was her name
and he's just all [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] shredded you know
and then his sister comes running out
well actually it was a cousin wasn't
what weren't they cousins i don't think
they were brother and sister
i think yeah i didn't think they were
either i think mellie mae was adopted
and they were man i haven't i haven't
seen it for a long time so i don't
remember i don't remember what the
relationship was between all of them
yeah and ellie mae was just some kind
she was the original desi duke she was
just this like blonde bombshell you know
and uh and didn't know she was
good-looking you know that was the the
funny thing about it
[Laughter]
all right we were sweeping home for like
an hour almost yeah yeah holy crap uh
yeah so gator it's free on youtube yeah
uh you don't have to have seen white
lightning
because i mean but you should i mean if
you want to see both but i'm just saying
that you don't like it's not like you
won't know what's going on no type of
thing but you don't see this you don't
see the character development arc
yeah and i think that's kind of one of
the most interesting things is that it's
yeah it's clearly the same character but
he's matured a lot since the first one
yeah uh so yeah you know check them out
they're free to watch and uh so yeah
we'll be back tomorrow talking about
that charles bronson movie that we've
mentioned the mechanic mechanic go check
that out so
do you want to just go ahead like i said
i'm this is totally off right whatever
but you want to just go ahead and push
all the matinees to five yeah let's just
make everything 5 p.m eastern standard
time okay instead of three because i
don't i don't know why we initially
started doing that in the first place i
don't know i don't know why we do a lot
of things camp guys straightened out
jethro was jed's nephew so jethro was
the one that was pearl's mom oh his
father was pearl that's right i kind of
that's right and ellie mae was actually
jed's daughter i believe the camp guy
said i don't know where ellie mae came
from
she just showed up one day well that's
right she called him she called him
uncle jed didn't she she called him
uncle jed didn't she call him uncle jack
i know i don't call her uncle jim i
don't know that's so long
it could be the ellie mayweather maybe
she got left when she was baby they left
her on the on the porch and a basket or
something right i don't know but yeah so
uh we'll be back tomorrow 5 p.m eastern
standard time
uh to talk about that charles bronson
movie so have a good rest of your
weekend everybody and we will see you
guys again tomorrow
bye